hi
everyone uh in this presentation i'm
gonna
show how to train your own neural
network
and then convert it to onyx and deploy
it to your
iphone so as uh as an example i'm gonna
train a mushroom classifier an image
classifier
uh with mushroom species from from my
region
and for this uh let's start with an
iconic
mushroom the fly agarik amanita muscaria
which it has its own emoji
and for this uh we can use uh
the species name amanita muscaria and
then use interpreter
and with the species to obtain the the
entity
of the fly algorithm and then as for
properties like the image and get this
thumbnail image in this case we want
hundreds of different images of all
kinds of
mushroom species so for this uh there is
a
new wall from function repository that i
did a couple of
months ago it's the i naturally search
function
you can explore with its documentation
it has
some examples basically it
it calls to the api from a naturalist
community it's a it's a
community of citizen scientists that
record all kinds of different
species into the wild
so for this uh we need to uh to get the
the function
uh using the resource function i
naturally you can
get the
the function and in the first argument
we will need to specify
the mushroom species and then
we want to make sure that it contains
the observation contains an image
and also we want to to make sure that
they are
research great observation that means
that at least
two other naturalist users
have agreed that that's a certain
species
and then we want to get
further for this case uh 50 images was
was
bringing uh it was creating a classifier
that was good enough
and you know i'm interested in species
that are in my region i live
in the front between france and spain in
northern catalonia
so i wanted to rule out some subspecies
that were
interstate for example so i could
ask for observations that are only in
europe using
observations geo range this will create
a data set of 50 observations
and for example this is the the data for
the first
for the first observation the data set
having
28 properties such as
the scientific name uh the
law firm species entity then there is
also
certain cases if if applicable there is
a
wiki data external identifier
and things like the geoposition
observation date
and here what we are interested is in
the images urls
and also just as an example so for those
who
who
haven't tried a natural release
it's a it's a nice platform in this case
this
amanita muscaria was found in in
denmark yeah
and uh for with welcome language it's
super easy to
to get the image with import
and the idea was that
i would build a image classifier with
some toxic mushrooms the most common
ones in my area
and some edible mushrooms 11
most common ones so
these are like some utility functions
for
getting the the images and then also
doing some
uh kind of cropping the center of the
image
and resizing them for later uh training
of general network
then i was storing the images
with export using the scientific name
and and also the attack
whether the mushroom was edible or toxic
poisonous
we can test that this function works
well with
another amanita the death cap which is a
deadly mushroom
and these are a few images that we got
from my naturalist
we can do the rest uh for for the rest
of the mushroom species
and then for for generating the training
set and testing set
i'm gonna create the class labels as
kind of a list of a strings
and create examples uh as a list of
key values the keys are the image and
and the values
are going to be the the labels
and we have 850 images examples
of these 17 mushroom species
so finally we only need to create a
randomized
training and test set which can be done
with a tick drop
random sample and the
thumb rule is to take 10 between 10 to
15
and keep it for the test testing set
so um for uh
doing the transfer learning i'm going to
use
a pre-trained uh net model from the wall
from net
repository for those who do don't know
about it that there's a bunch of uh
pre-trained neural networks
which can be useful for uh your task
here i'm gonna focus on the the warframe
image identify net
version 1 which was the one also i think
originally
used for the image identify built-in
function
you can get the model simply using net
model and the name of the
model and
a good thing to do is also to check the
the size of the
of the network since we are aiming to to
deploy it into the
into a smartphone it should not be much
bigger than
100 megabytes in this case it's a 60
megabytes
so what we are interested is in the
in the this part here from the
compositional
first compositional layer to the
totalized
pulling layer so we will use the net dig
on the bridge net and then using the
net join and we can add a linear layer
with 17 classes and a softbox layer and
finally
an output with a decoder with the
classes that
class labels that we created earlier
so then as a last type we just need to
to train it
with net train uh keeping the the
pre-trained weights fixed
and also adding a validation set for
around uh
10 percent of the training set and for
for me it was
yielding already good results doing 15
training rounds and the method is a
stochastic gradient descent
and it was doing a fairly good job
it took around like 9 minutes
on cpu on my macbook pro
and so we can also now check the
performance
plotting the confusion matrix either
using the net measurements or the
classifier measurements function
here was using the classifier
measurements which we can
create a confusion matrix plot and check
which ones were misidentified actually
these
three here are all of them edible and
they're quite similar actually
so a nice thing to do is with classifier
measurements
result we can also ask for the best
classified
examples and as well for the the worst
ones
so it seems it had difficulty to
classify correctly these ones
but you can see that they have some
certain weird angles
some is covered with some leaf and this
is even
a rotten mushroom it seems
but yeah we can can also test
with a dessert example and and
in this particular case it was doing a
pretty good job
as a good practice uh i recommend you to
to also
to export the mysham warframe uh net
models
in using the the the from language net
format so you
in in case that you are restarting your
session you don't you don't need to to
train again
the model all right the next step is
it's
it's to sport export the trinity net
model
uh using as on file on x file
so onyx is a it's the open
neural network exchange file format that
was created
some time ago i don't know if it was
like a couple of years ago
by some big parties in the industry of
machine learning
and now there's a lot of companies
supporting that
file format and now in 12.2 we have also
the option to directly export both from
language neural network models into onex
directly using export
so a good way to do is a kind of
round trip check that the the converted
model was converted properly by just
importing back
again into the notebook and as you will
see
the models the original model was a net
chain
and the imported one is a net graph
there
they have the same layers but the
one x doesn't have the encoder
and the decoder so that means that we
need to
dress up the neural network again using
for example um the net extract from the
original model
uh and then get the encoder
and as well as the decoder
we can use net replace part on the
imported onyx model
and then we will end up having a
a ready to train the neural network and
not to drain but to test sorry
so in this case i'm using this toxic
mushroom
to test on both models the original one
and the onyx one
and they seem to to be doing the right
thing
they have the same output probabilities
so it worked
as a last step we need to convert
this on onex model into a core
ml if we want to deploy it into a an ios
operating
system device so like an ipad or an
iphone
and apple released a python package
called coreml tools
for importing all types of
net models and you can see that there
they also have support
for onyx so it's going to be
one last step before deploying the net
to the iphone for this
uh i was following the instructions too
from from this workflow
uh that you can check i shared the by
the way i shared
the whole presentation notebook on
on the possible link
and then if you're not familiar with
the external uh evaluate function
you you can just follow the steps here
and be read and be able to run python
code
directly on your notebook you will also
need to
install the the coreml tools from apple
python package as well as the onyx one
once that you have that
it's uh it's good to know
to know that the kind of core ml models
uh they have a similar way of working as
the wall from language models which
with this i mean that they have a kind
of encoder and decoder
so we will need to specify from the onyx
model
during the compression of linux mode to
core ml to specify
some pre-processing arguments
and also add the class labels for the
mushrooms
so in particular we have to pay
attention to
to the input port and check
uh certain properties here
in this case uh we want to make sure
that the image the main image of each
color channel is also pre-processed
correctly
in the core ml model and
also you should be aware that the pixel
values range are from from zero to one
in the wall from language
uh but in core ml the scale is from zero
to 255
so we will need to also in the
pre-processing
arguments we will need to specify the
image scale
as well uh that the the color bias which
are mainly the
the net that
the values from from the main image
up here and for uh
kind of specifying the class labels we
only need to
export as a text file the class labels
separated by a new line and this will
be specified here i'm not gonna
enter in too much detail on the python
code but this is all
what you need for specifying the path of
the
the onyx exported model
and then also save the model the ml
model
with a proper name and folder
and once this uh if all this works uh
well you will get such an output of
converting all the layers from on x to
core ml
and hopefully it will
at the end say something like model
compilation
uh done and then we we can
test it with the core ml tools uh that
the model is is behaving well
and here you will need to import as well
uh the numpy
package as well as the pil
one to import a test image here
is a parcel mushroom
so and then doing some image resizing
and
check for that the top three
probabilities
and these are the outputs and we can
check with
our original waveform and model
which uh the probabilities are pretty uh
pretty much the same
with acceptance of with an error of
order 10 to the minus 2
which uh it's it's kind of fine since
they're doing some
different image pre-processing
so we have a kind of
core ml model working well we only need
to to deploy it to
to the iphone for this um
last step you will need to register as
an apple developer
and download the install the xcode beta
you will not need to know swift
programming languages here
so we will need only to to download
the classifying images with a
vision and core ml tutorial from apple
and downloading this xcode project
will give you such window i think
i have xcode open here so
instead of and here you will see instead
of this mushroom
wall from net you will see a mobile net
neural net model which
you have to replace it for this one
and here you can see that we have
already our mushroom
species labels 17
and also the layers distribution and as
in the preview section we can
test already directly on xcode without
needing to deploy it to the iphone
so let's try with some toxic mushroom
ammonite followed this
and you can see that it's working
already
well
as a final step
uh you need uh to modify
one of the swift uh files the
actual it's the the image classy
classification view controller
file here you need to replace the mobile
net
for the your own
model so here's the mushrooms over from
net
and once you add this class here you are
good to go and connect your iphone
and then press the the button for build
and then run
and that should be it i think
here there is some tests that i was
doing
in the forest i think uh during the
weekend
so i will just show you the screen of
the iphone i was going to into the woods
and i found the mushroom
and actually i took it and
i was eating it so i'm still alive it
was not
the second option which would be like
deadly
and these are some other mushrooms i've
also found during the last days
and all of them were correctly
classified
yeah i was double checking checking it
with some
mushroom expert
and if you have any question i would
like to
to answer it and please
check check out the the notebook and
and think it and that's that's pretty
much
it uh in the future i would like to also
to do it uh
one example with uh but
it probably will take more uh more
swift code for in this process but yeah
is there any question should i check
refresh the
question from from danny about how well
so comparing different models i think
that the best one right now is
sufficient net
and which is gonna be available uh in in
12.2
so um i would advise you to
uh check efficientnet in the future
uh which is the the best performing one
you should be careful on not taking a an
efficient
efficient net model which is uh too
heavy in memory
that they can be up to almost one
gigabyte or so or even more
so you should take some kind of
light efficient net i think that these
are the
the best performing ones so in the
future i should also
do an example using efficientnet
uh yeah i i should i should warn you
that uh
this was just a toy example uh so
uh do not use this classifier for for
cooking without
expert consultation actually
mushrooms can be quite deadly
yeah i think
i was not completely putting my life uh
in hands of war from technology so so i
really uh
also consulted with my grandma which has
more experience
on mushrooms than me
i think in in the near future i will
kind of create a workflow for for
for this presentation and and maybe uh
even brighter
offering blog post about it and
i hope to also have more examples uh
that are not just uh image
classification
examples but yeah
maybe the next one is gonna be one for
audio
i think i would say that uh yeah my
grandma is
a great experience on the edible
mushrooms
but he doesn't know much about the the
real toxic ones
so i would also check the
a good guide or yeah and and then
i think the best one is also to um
upload the picture on i naturally ask
for expert consultation
experts there and yeah
if you have some some kind of
doubts that the mushroom could be toxic
you should not eat it because there are
like so many species of mushrooms
here i was using 17 but they are
actually uh
many more
i mean so this is toxic but some people
are eating
uh amanita muscaria in some some
cultures
and it's also psychoactive if you boil
it really well it's not psychoactive or
neither
toxic but it's always a risk
uh right that so
i i was thinking uh to start with uh
some audio identification of uh
bird songs i did uh my from summer
school project a long time ago on that
but i should update it with the new
audio functions and
and and it's a bit tricky because the
the the audio
um encoder for the of the identifier
it's a bit different than the image uh
encoder but
i think it's going to be at some point
an example on that
so yes i think at some
point i would like also to create a
study group on such
applications and topics
yeah uh for for android uh it's
it's uh up to the onyx point it's the
same workflow
and from there you have different
options
as uh there's there's on x runtime and
i haven't uh work any work out any
example
there might be some examples from others
at some point soon
yeah for for importing um species
observations there are also some
other uh functions i did in the past
like i naturally import gpif search
gpif import and global data
i think this three here can be also
useful for you
to build up some some classifiers on
on animals or plants
all right i think
there are no new questions right
so thank you very much
for your attention and hope
if there are more questions you can
always ask maybe
in the machine learning group in
community and i will try to
have a kind of check them